el llamado sueño americano ha quedado
condicionado por la situación económica
en Estados Unidos la creciente inflación
y el encarecimiento del costo de vida
provocaron que el acceso a un inmueble
sea difícil para los ciudadanos y
generaron una caída en las ventas Bueno
creo que en este punto Estamos buscando
esa corrección en el mercado y está
sucediendo con las tasas de interés
actualmente en 7%. realmente Es un shock
para algunos compradores
sin embargo otros vendedores se
mantienen optimistas Y esperan que la
situación se normalice pronto
sinceramente no estoy de acuerdo ni
justifico este gran miedo no creo que
sea lo que la gente está construyendo
con las opiniones divididas analistas
aseguran que las tasas de interés
bajarán cuando se reduzca la inflación y
mientras tanto ofrecen otras
alternativas
creo que hay un par de soluciones una es
ahorrar un poco más y la otra es comprar
una casa más barata de lo que sería de
otro modo
la combinación de altas tasas de interés
Y todavía mucha incertidumbre sobre la
inflación significa que la gente está
postergando las compras creo que va a
continuar por un tiempo con más del 7%
el mercado inmobiliario estadounidense
afronta la mayor tasa hipotecaria desde
el 2002 y duplica el pico máximo
registrado en 2021 en tanto que según la
asociación de banqueros hipotecarios la
demanda de hipotecas está en su ritmo
más lento desde 1997